[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CAROLYN JONS: This is
Goodie Bag number nine.
In today's video,
we will be exploring
the topics of polymerization
and cross-linking
and learning how
these processes can
be used to make slime at home.
You'll need gloves,
Elmer's glue, borax powder,
plastic cups, and
spoons for stirring.
One product made of polymers
that many people are
familiar with is Silly Putty.
Silly Putty is made of a polymer
called polydimethylsiloxane.
Polydimethylsiloxane
is made of repeating
units called monomers that
include a silicon, an oxygen,
and two CH3 groups.
Today we're going to make
an alternative material that
behaves a little bit
like Silly Putty,
but is instead made of
a different polymer.
This can be made by
combining Elmer's glue
and cross-linking with borax.
As you can see, after I added
borax to the Elmer's glue,
the material became
much more viscous.
This is because
of cross-linking.
Cross-linking is forming
a bond to link one polymer
chain to another.
In this experiment,
the polyvinyl alcohol
and Elmer's glue forms hydrogen
bonds with the boric acid.
These cross-links make it
more difficult for the polymer
chains to slide
past one another,
so the material
becomes more viscous.
By adding in more borax,
we increase the number
of cross-links, and this
results in a material
more resistant to flow.
You may have noticed that
when we pull quickly,
the slime breaks in half.
But when we pull slowly, the
slime is able to stretch.
This is because the slow pulling
allows hydrogen bonds to break
and then reform, allowing the
chains to more easily slide
past one another.
In this Goodie Bag, we
hope you had an opportunity
to make a polymer of your own
and witness how cross-linking
can change material properties.